one star who is not playing in the pro  bowl tom brady today he made his own  news he announced his retirement brady  considered by almost everybody to be the  best quarterback in nfl history six  super bowls with new england one last  year with tampa bay  after 22 seasons in the nfl brady says  he's finally ready to step back  fans say they're disappointed but they  understand brady's decision  i'm definitely happy for him  especially like for his family he's got  a whole family to raise and  i wish i could see him another year but  he's doing what's best for him  [Applause]  i mean he is what 44 45 years old  brady's throwing more touchdowns for  more yards won more playoff games than  any other player in league history phil